some welcoming news for many of you
trying to find work at this time and
maybe worried about unemployment
benefits running out benefits will be
extended right through the week ending
september 4th
this comes as a part of the recently
signed american rescue plan act
some claimants may see a delay in those
benefits as dieter is waiting
and for some direction from the
department of labor on how exactly to
implement this plan
joe mohler live at dieter tonight with
more information about that extension
joe
well as you can imagine unemployment
claimants are happy to hear about this
extension but that delay is
obviously a concern for them now dieter
is going to be reviewing this new law
and they need
guidance from the department of labor
before they can implement it
this will extend benefits through
september 4th like you had mentioned now
pua and peuc recipients may experience a
delay of
several weeks you will receive all the
weeks you are eligible but the ui
system will be processing those existing
claims in batches
the extra weekly 300 is also included in
this
earlier today we spoke to caitlin millis
who was a spa manager on the strip she
says this gives people time as
industries
slowly come back to life it is a little
bit of a relief
from my perspective to be able to kind
of
still kind of situate kind of work out
what i want to do with my
my career you know do i continue on that
career path
and try to apply for jobs once they
start opening up after people get
vaccinated
when the continued assistance act which
extended benefits through march 13th was
passed it took
three weeks for dieter to receive
updated guidance from the federal
government
you do not need to take any action to
receive extended benefits under this new
law other than continuing to file
weekly claims